bon j'ai un truc à dire ouais quoi voilà
avant de sortir avec toi j'ai
fréquentèrent notre homme ça c'est pas
grave je sais mais c'est normal moi
c'était ton frère euh c'est pas la salle
pas suffi parce que j'ai aussi eu une
aventure avec ton cousin le petit lucas
ouais le petit lucas et puis aussi avec
avec stephen stuut meilleur ami bon je
veux juste me réconforter après une
histoire et que ton père puisse pas fini
parce que aussi il ya eu pascal il ya eu
martin solveig de l'app store il ya eu
frédéric il ya une elson cédric super
cool ah ben oui quand on pense à tous
ces enfants gérard envie ni bernard en
même temps elle projette enita sérologie
en plus jeunes
pascaline constant que tous annoncent il
ya eu jérémy aussi merci pour tous et à
bientôt